picture a SmartWatch in your mind's eye
and it probably looks something like
this
in fact even a normal wristwatch looks
like this there's a case and there's a
band that attaches that case to your arm
but wrist watches have been following
that form factor for literally hundreds
of years and when you think about it in
those terms
contemporary SmartWatch design is
actually kind of boring a company called
poly era has taken a new approach with a
flexible wearable touchscreen it calls
the wolf and the device won't hit the
market till 2016 but we had a chance to
visit Pali Arras offices and play with
some prototypes unrolled the wolf man
looks like somebody crossed a Kindle
with a slap bracelet but wrap it around
your wrist and the display wraps with it
it's pretty impressive to see an action
and vital to the company's mission to
change the way we wear technology the
philosophy behind wove is really one
which we summarized in Digital ghost
material the traditional displays we
interact with our glass vase are very
bright you really have a feeling that
it's a clearer than our case in between
the physical and digital world and you
kind of look into the digital world
through a window we are about creating a
new kind of medium which is about
bringing digital content out into the
physical world a big advantage of the
wool fans form-factor
is the size of its display poly arrow
wants its users to make the most of that
real estate with something it's calling
compositions they're sort of like apps
but designed to be worn an accent on a
large always-on display with the woven
polyester canonical two-component
wristwatch design thrown it out the
window in doing so they're hoping to
expand the possibilities of what a wrist
worn wearable can be